It's weird being in voice chat and not being allowed to spell all the secrets of what I've got planned.
Oh no, it's starting!
It's starting!
Here, here.
Oh, so excited.
Did it just pause? It says three.
Yeah, it's supposed to.
Uh-oh.
Oh no!
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, wait.
Technical difficulties, it's fine lives, it's fine, Luna.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
They're so cute, I can't.
Wait, I'm gonna unmute.
I just realized I've not got desktop audio in their split, so I can't hear the streaming you guys can.
How did you guys split the audio?
I've got you guys captured via desktop.
Oh, you have to, you have to make, um, what's it called?
A split.
Yeah, you guys split in OBS so you can do it.
Yeah, that's what I did.
I have two tips.
I have my headset and my IEMs right now.
Oh no.
I hear them.
I've bowled this watch a long time ago, that's all I can say so far.
I'll mute it once they finish their intro.
Oh.
Hello.
Gushy.
Right.
Gishy, Gishy.
I'm like, I got two things she could gush on right here.
Oh, everyone says it's very sweet.
They helped with the watch along.
I know they're helping them with a big concert.
Yeah.
Hey, man, you scratch our back, we scratch yours.
That's how we do it from around these parts.
Mimosa's a good singer.
Yeah.
Dude, Mimosa's so talented.
She is.
I actually got them lungs on her just hiding.
You wouldn't realize.
Don't be fooled by the outfit.
There's lungs under this.
I know.
Damn.
Her model's so bouncy.
It is.
I love that.
I love the way eyelashes.
I know it's not a V-tube or mainstream, but I know.
I was just like strawberries.
I want to eat them.
The flowers in her ears.
I just let's.
It's a different place.
So nice.
Oh, the breadsticks in chat.
Oh.
I like her custom mic.
I didn't even notice.
Oh, it's really cool.
God, I was talking about customized assets today,
and I was like, I never got girls anything.
It was OK.
I was just like, that was, it sounds terrible.
I was like, if I'm not going to use it,
I'm not giving it to them.
Because I showed my end in screen for like the first time
and literally since debut, I showed my end in screen
and everyone was laughing.
Why do you hate the ending screen so much?
I just ends.
She just leaves.
I don't like heart screams.
Literally, if you open up one of my boards,
I'm just like, I don't know.
I literally spent so much money on it.
I just never use the thing.
I've never even seen the stingers.
I never even used stingers on debut.
That's so much I hate them as well.
So I'm showing them the debut.
God, this is fantastic.
This is beyond my expectations.
Mom, this is amazing.
She's like an amazing, amazing singer.
Multi, multi, multi-talented.
Extremely.
Things, streams.
Freaking makes all her own charts as well.
Thumbnails.
You name it.
She does it.
She does them all.
You didn't know she sings.
Well, I'm supposed to keep up with everyone's talents
and the VTuber roster that I'm not aware of.
That's what I thought we'd be from.
You're not constantly stalking when most is channeling me.
Well, that's why I'm supposed to know absolutely everything
about every other VTuber that's been kind enough
to interact with me.
That's right.
You're done for a reason bend over.
Prepare yourself.
What was it?
Tyler.
Hello, everybody.
Hi, Harold.
Something is in my eye.
My eye.
Well, we have a peak refunds.
So I'm surfing the teeth.
Anyone can hear that?
No, I don't.
OK.
Meru!
freak A1 your custom microphone.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, she's insane.
Oh my god, duet!
Oh my god, how long is this concert?
That is like some built-in and pre-pro-new-
I'm like generally so impressed with the most of his voice in Burroughs.
Me too!
I wish I could speak Japanese!
Imagine us up there.
Konichiwawa.
I forget singing in English.
I can even imagine singing in a different language.
Exactly.
I think we got to get some Japanese speakers for Gen 2, mommy.
We're being influenced live.
You heard it here, folks.
I saw what you tweeted, Chibi.
I don't think I didn't see it.
She went on Twitter and she tweeted a sling girl.
Aw, don't look at me.
I'm not doing nothing.
I freaking saw it.
I'm just slowly just putting it into your mind.
I will get you a Halloween variation outfit of you as a sling girl.
Absolutely.
Yeah?
All yours.
I'm not having an actual sling girl.
Yeah!
I'm giving the sling girl!
Yes.
All right.
I'll settle.
I'll settle for that.
I'm the sling girl.
We've defeated the sling allegation.
Yeah!
I'm so...
I'm trying not to scream.
I'm trying to focus on the thing because I'm about to get real giddy.
Things are jiggling on screen.
I don't know if what you guys are looking at, but things are jiggling to me.
Two things are jiggling.
Slime bunny girl, like from Queen's Blade, precisely.
A cotton bum family member is going to be the slime girl.
I'll have to think about that.
Sublime.
She's slimy.
What are you doing?
Shebeth the Slime.
Oh my god.
Look at her little freaking...
Look at her little pony tails, Bob.
Yaeli.
Yaeli fish ribbons as well, like the translucent.
Such a good design.
Unfortunately, it's my turn to sing.
Hold on.
Let me get my pen lights out.
No!
No eye moner.
Should we get eye trackers?
I'll do that.
I'll give every girl an eye tracker and we'll watch the most devious videos and stuff.
And then we'll see who's got like 93% pervert rate.
Why is Mamosa so good?
Mamosa, why is Mero so good?
Did they die?
Oh, discord crashed.
Sorry, I died.
I'm asking Mero if she wants to go up on stage because she's watching this.
I think her makes fucking dying.
Yeah, we can't really hear you.
Azura, are you alive?
I'm fine.
I'll take that.
She's so excited.
She's so, so excited to get on stage.
She just ran away.
She's like at the thought, at the concert.
Let me get two pen lights out.
I don't have different colors.
I only have blue.
I have so many questions for them about how long this took.
This is insane.
I know.
They should just like take the soundtracks here and just post them as song covers too.
Honestly, that's a smart idea.
I think they should.
I think they will.
You think they will?
I hope so.
Because it's really good.
They shouldn't just leave it here on the stream.
I want full song covers.
Let us hear your lungs.
This tiny jellyfish got lungs on her too.
God dang.
Azura is singing along to it.
I think that's why she's muted.
Damn.
That's where you're not beating the weave allegations.
This concert is epic.
Literally.
I had no idea what to expect.
I've never actually sat through it.
This is so cool.
Uncle, give us another mate.
I don't know why this creature is dying for me.
It's hard to know.
I'm just so surprised at the stage.
All the assets.
The light show.
It's really pretty.
Mara is so cute.
She is.
This is so cool.
She has her tentacles bounce.
Is Azura's mute at the audio?
She's going to get coffee.
I mean.
The reminder not to play the audio of the stream.
On stream.
Question of those headlights being held up by my arms.
Oh, this goes hard.
Got a different vibe.
If I'm he started singing in Japanese, I would have absolutely lost my mind.
Wait, is she about to?
I think this is an English cover.
If you guys had to sing a song for a concert, what would you sing?
That's my question.
I would rap something ridiculous.
ABC's.
Sing five bars, five seconds.
Two in your mom live edition.
Why does this court keep shitting the bed?
Lincoln Park calling you.
There you go.
I streamed a fish.
I probably do American.
I like green.
Okay.
I may go off.
Hit him.
Hey, don't hurt him now.
Kill him.
That's so cool.
Oh, no, she's hot.
I just set the ambiance.
Feel that music.
Feel them tunes.
I saw it.
Execute me.
I me.
I don't know if you guys have ever played Alice Madness Returns, but when you get low health,
you enter a state of hysteria and you unlock a different version like to your look.
And this I me is like completely making me want to play Alice Madness Returns right now.
That's a great game.
I've heard of that game.
I want to play it too.
Oh, I recommend.
I me darkness way.
Yeah.
I me darkness dementia way.
Just like my immortal.
I love her mic too.
All the song choices are really good too.
They're all catchy.
I'm in.
Oh, shit.
Execution.
I'm too more to add them to the rest.
Three.
Whoa.
They're all singing together.
Are there songs that support this?
What is it?
Oh, wait.
This is crazy.
It's not just like one solo song or do it.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
YouTube does need anime emotes.
Someone's using a pickle instead of the baguettes.
Put your pickle away.
I love Amara bounces her little tentacle ponytails.
Yay.
I must have taken so much work to practice.
I have so many questions for them after this.
Like, holy crap.
I'm sorry.
I'm not singing in Japanese.
No, I'm not going to ask you to.
Holy crap.
I would never ask you to sing in another language.
Japanese fans would hate me because I would just butcher everything.
Because I would not be able to.
This is so beautiful and amazing.
I'm sorry, but.
I should have said sorry.
I'll do Megan the stallion song.
What does she want?
I didn't hear that new one from Megan the stallion.
I forgot the name of the faking song.
I already forgot the name of the song too.
I was listening to it this morning.
It's your time up.
I need some Japanese songs to sing.
Japanese?
That's okay.
I'll sing that part of it.
What's up?
It happens by own words.
And the birds and the eagles.
I will sing that version.
Some of the uptails on it that aren't real words.
I just want to smush her little face.
She gives me cute aggression.
I have seen the Japanese version of Doja Cat say so.
It is very good.
It's very cute.
I'm making the Scottish version and getting a million views.
You should.
In the moment, I want to say so.
I love this song.
I just got shivers.
Her voice is so clear.
I'm getting shivers from her singing.
If you guys want to do song collabs,
I can set the other VTubers for you.
That would be fun.
I love this song.
Do you want to sing magnet with me?
Vocaloid magnet?
I don't know what that is.
Am I aging myself right now?
No.
Let me look it up.
Maybe I'm forgetting the name.
Miku.
And forbidden lovers.
I've never heard this one.
No.
You've never heard magnet?
It's from Chibi Collab.
Jason.
Do you want to do magnet with me?
You're asking the wrong one.
You were singing a
Ed Sheeran's thing of the whole bit.
My voice is so broken.
We have mixers.
We'll do a recorded concert.
I'm just a me.
You did not even sound like that.
Come off it.
Come off it now.
There you use these
terminologies again.
I'll make a comment.
I'll be very interested to see
how your accent would develop.
Chibi had never done it before until
debut.
Then we did the debut mock and she goes
Arise.
Where did this come from?
I was studying.
I was, I was, uh, holding my inner Scott since I'm Scottish myself and my mom's side and my mom's side.
Oh, you're more hen. I probably can or then.
I didn't. Yeah, my great-grandmother immigrated from Scotland. I didn't even know that.
That's so cool. I'm here for it.
Oh, she got her love eyes on. She got her love eyes on.
Hell yeah. Go little joke. Go little joke. Go little joke. Go.
My jokes.
The song is really good.
Maybe like the song.
Is this where I see it in me that her song's being mixed right now?
Oh, it's, that's Fortnite Battle Pass.
You're doing Fortnite Battle Pass as a,
I don't even know what to tell them what the plan was.
Go ahead.
So I really like Amy's voice and I wanted her to make a meme song cover.
And the one song I really wanted her to cover is the song that's Fortnite Metal Pass.
That'll go viral. I'll tell you that right now. This is my prediction.
She was alive while she was away on holiday, but unfortunately we were having a lot of delay issues just everywhere.
But she drew her own artwork for it. I'm getting it animated and then it's been turned into a little cute video,
but it's less than a minute long, so I'm going to get it into...
They're together!
Sorry.
Because she cut herself off.
Yeah, Rhea!
We stan Vocaloid. Shadow Wizard Money Gang.
We love Vocaloid.
Oh my God, Rain's voice is so mummy.
I love that Rain has like a slight valley accent.
Does she?
Yeah.
I didn't notice.
It's very, very slight.
It fits her model so well though.
It does.
I actually just wanted to really...
Did these were jumping?
Sorry, I'm a child. I'm an absolute child.
Forgive me.
Veiler Fortnite skins? Absolutely not.
Could you imagine?
It was like cash money flow emo on someone after you kill them and it's just Emmys fans.
She's in her jays like dancing over the cars with someone because she got first place.
Oh my God.
Oh, I would do an Arata Shigako song.
I really like Tokyo Calling because it's about...
You're going to say Tokyo Drift.
No, no, no. It's called Tokyo Calling and it's about how dystopian your life can become
if you don't kind of find the meaning of it or that's what I took away from it and it's like...
One of the lines that really resonates me is like...
They're singing magnet? Are they?
Shut up.
I'm going to lose it.
They are singing magnet. Oh my God, I'm literally going to cry.
This is one of my favorite Vocaloid songs.
Oh my God, actually.
I'm geeking out. I'm geeking.
Riefland's almost... I was actually...
Hatsune Miku was my entrance into the anime world to say the things. I said what I said.
Are they going to do the Japanese or the English version?
That's my question.
The world?
Oh, they're doing the Japanese.
Duuu duuu duuu duuu duuu duuu duu duuu duuu duuu duuu duuu duaa duuu duuu duuu duuu duuu duuu hello.
Creaming your jarts.
They were creamed long ago. Thank you.
Reia's voice.
I love Reia's singing voice. Oh my God.
She sounds so like...
It's a little bit more mature. It's so clear and smooth.
I think almost ethereal. You know that?
Yeah, absolutely. Every time she opens, she sings, it gives me servers.
servers. Oh, this takes me back.
I'm so happy right now. I like
Rains Mike. Mom, can we get
mics? Okay, get makes. Actually,
this is insider knowledge. You
guys aren't supposed to know
this, but you can't keep a secret
for the life of you. I started
it. I was like, oh, everyone
else can know that's listening
into a I haven't met any of the
girls in August and they can
have we are going to discuss
alternative outfits. Well, I
already know I'm getting slime.
Well, that's for Halloween. But
like Halloween. Oh, shit. I'm
under way. Oh, God. Well, you
just said we're gonna be for
Halloween. She forgot what she
said. If we're doing Halloween
costumes, I'm gonna need to fill
some string. If you guys want
Halloween costumes, you must
tell me in the meeting. I want
to be a slamber for Halloween.
I don't know what I'm going to
do for my alternate outfit. I saw
you do that. I think I'm going
to save the idea for 2.0.
Please remember when if you guys
would like to sign on for the
next year, we also offer a free
alternate outfit on the house.
So if you have one idea you like,
but it's not what you go for, we
can probably cover it later.
Thanks, Trani. Again, inside
your knowledge. If you work
under Vealer and sign on for
the next year, your split goes
up and further 5% in your
favor. Oh my gosh.
Aren't I just pulling them
strings?
My ever self sacrificing
mother. She's shilling.
What do you mean? You don't like
the way that we rain cloud?
Making kills while watching a
concert.
Oh, strongy.
Make sure she gets so excited.
That's why.
Bro, I literally leak everything.
I like all of this place.
I don't know because A.C. is
going to be in the meeting about
all of this unfolding.
So when's that meeting supposed
to be?
I'll I don't know August 1st.
August 1st. I'll just put that
down, pencil. Someday.
What's the August, September,
October? No, I want to.
Maybe it was just like short
notice. Or maybe she wasn't
feeling good. It's a lot.
It's a lot of practice.
Stress. It is stressful as
well. Yeah. Yeah, get all that
stuff done.
Look at I.B. just bow bobbing
up and down. She's like, yep,
yep, yep, yep, I'm ready.
Of her jacket came comes up
with her.
And she bubbles.
Oh, I love them.
Sorry, I'm a wee sump.
Yeah, we love we stand Kingdom
Hearts in this home.
This Kingdom Hearts good. I
never had the opportunity.
I thought the plan for October
was giggle sticks.
No, no, no, I had.
Oh, my God, the script master
got an absolute bolligan and I
got a refund on some stuff.
Yeah, as you should.
I will I'm going to rewrite it
myself. I'm not even going to
hide you.
Well, apparently he might have
already rewrote it.
I've not looked at it, but I
am. I'm I will I'm going to
take a peek right now.
Yeah, take a peek.
He replaced giggle sticks with
a light stick.
Oh, could you imagine?
OK, I stopped meeting in the
script now and it's just like
fucking substitutes instead.
Just rate clock.
What?
It's going on.
Patriot, it's fine.
Honestly, the fucking
the disc stick on us.
Nuzzle Fudge.
Awful.
OK, literally just took out all
of the direction.
Oh, is the actual script usable?
He left in cock-suckery.
Cock-suckery.
I mean, if you can overlook that
as a script usable question,
Mark, we're not going to have to
go in and I honestly
have been I have a bad taste in
my mouth, although I'll talk
about this later.
We'll talk about this later.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Concert, concert, concert.
You know, business, business,
business, business, business, business.
This is a great song, too.
My light stick burns brighter than
ever.
I got my light sticks here.
Go off by me.
Don't forget to check out the link
in the description, guys, because
I've got all their links on YouTube.
Like, they have worked so hard on
this concert, even a cheeky song.
And I like on the stream right now.
I pinned it in my chat.
Just give it a cheeky, like, let
them know that I fucking enjoyed
this because this is.
Like, I know you could argue, oh,
they're only singing a three minute
song. No, behind the scenes.
Are you kidding me?
There's so much.
So much stuff.
All while they were streaming as
well in the background, they would
have had to have been streaming and
then, like, do vocal practice, do
warm-up practice songs, record, get
it sent to a mixer, edits, or, like,
just be good to them, OK?
Be good to be nice.
Bambigets, yes.
Welcome to Bambigets in the chat.
Let them know the reflins showed up.
I heard the song in such a long
time.
I hear them.
Shut up.
That's months of presence.
You can see all the reflins in the
chat forgetting.
Good reflins.
I see you well.
That's what I like to see.
You all get rewarded.
Yeah, make sure to click on the link
in my chat. Give them a give them a
like.
So up to their channels, up to the
girls. I have very stuff in my
description and all the other girls
do too. So.
Is Mercy in here?
Is she?
No, Mercy's not here.
Mercy's by her lone son.
OK.
She said she would yap too much
also.
Yeah, because she's like, I'm going
to be real. I'm going to be mad
annoying.
She's probably like also geeking
out right now.
It's probably it's like yapping a
bunch.
My sweet Mercy.
I was going to pretend that rain
was like just tearing up on the
guitar.
Yeah, I'm going to do it.
Shrondi, can you play the
instruments?
No, I never learned.
I was athletic.
Oh, what kind of athletics?
And I was called
athletics and swimming as well.
And I'm I running
like athletics and the hurdle
athletics and anything that has
to do with their grippers.
I'm not being the grippers.
Someone commented on my feet.
They were like, you have very long
toes. And I'm like, sorry, you
stuffed your toes so much that
they're like fucking nubs.
But I used me.
I have regular toes.
If you didn't know, you're supposed
to be able to walk on them, not like
a little stubbly fucking way.
Like fucking toes.
And she took that personally.
Honestly.
But I'm saying my toes are long.
My toes are normal.
All together.
Harmony is the melody of the heart.
I can't stop sharing it.
Reigns boobs.
It's when she bounces, we bounce
so like lately, they're like
in and out.
Oh, my God, that's another trio.
That's so impressive.
It's so impressive.
It's got the lungs for this.
I'm I'm tired just thinking
and can say I know what I'm saying.
I mean.
Oh, don't hurt them.
No, don't hurt them.
I also have long toes.
Nothing wrong.
You can really grip it with those
long toes. Yeah.
Grip what?
It.
Group songs are much harder to mix
together, too.
I mean, I feel like it's not hard
to mix anything when it comes to
these girls because they just
naturally sound perfectly.
Oh, yeah.
They're speaking voices, they're
singing voices.
Yeah.
Stoney can clap real good.
Oh, we flint.
Grip in the grippy stick with my
grippers.
OK, no.
I want that as a tramp stamp on
my model. Thank you.
Nuzlin, the fast, fast one.
That's with my grippers.
I don't know.
I wonder what mic she uses,
Raya, because her stuff is so
clear.
I know.
Oh, thank you for the gift,
it boy.
Who that boy?
Who him is?
I'm not OK, Tyler.
Go off.
No.
I'm too pasty to see that song.
Are you enjoying it, Zara?
I just heard our giggle.
I tell you.
Oh, my God.
This is fantastic.
Imagine this in 3D.
Oh, that would be so good.
I would be pissing myself.
Same.
I didn't know how 3D concerts
work.
I didn't know you were going to
ask me for a Mariah about that.
Yeah.
He didn't say their knowledge.
Come on, lad.
Come on, Reflin's pill or bring
one, bring one, bring one, bring
one, bring one.
Come on, Reflin's pill or bring
one, bring one, bring one.
Go do the work.
Go on, Reflin's.
Go on.
There was this company that
helped Uteno Pandora
to do her 3D concert
and it's an upcoming company.
And I was like, ooh.
Oh, my God.
Inside her knowledge, too,
I met Uteno Pandora before
she debuted and before I debuted.
That's so cool.
Yeah, it's so cool.
I mean, she doesn't know that.
She doesn't know that we met
before, but I know that we met
before.
Oh, my God.
That's cool, though.
She was so nice to me.
She's so lovely, but I don't
interact with her anymore
because she doesn't know who I
am. Smile.
Smile.
She's so, so lovely.
Grin.
Yeah.
And her goal was to have a 3D
concert and she achieved it.
Oh, she achieved it.
That's so sweet.
I love girlies
in their dreams.
Achieved.
Achieved those goals.
You're only holding yourself back.
This is a good ray of bobble.
I love seeing how they move
their models.
I wonder if...
What?
It's not ogre yet, is it?
No, I'm core.
Come on, get back on the stage.
God damn.
We didn't finish it.
Oh, an idol song.
We're mollans
and aimless
in song together.
Is that a...
Is that a Zora?
Yeah!
Are you enjoying it?
Are you having fun as Zora?
Yeah!
I didn't realise how reactive
Mimosa's ears are.
Yeah.
They are.
They're all well-read.
Mmm.
And her boobs, too.
I know, I can't stop sharing
everyone's boobs.
I have really bad eyes, though.
So sometimes Mimosa's arms
look like a part of her hair.
And she's a little nuggy.
Is she like a little nuggy?
You know what I love it.
Her arms are very thin,
so they tend to kind of
disappear into her hair, for sure.
She's our little nugget.
My little nugget.
I want chicken nuggets.
Oh my god, I had really good
chicken nuggets yesterday.
I know this is completely off-dolting,
but it's fucking delicious.
I was like,
I have bad eyes.
This is not an excuse to stare at boobs.
Let me alone.
Oh, get it, get it, get it, get it.
This is so hate.
Hate.
Yeah, Mimosa's voice.
Mimosa's voice.
Her mouth tracking is really good.
Nothing wrong with wanting
some strawberry milk.
Get out of here.
My question is,
are they doing a five-man song
at the end?
I bet.
I hope so.
I hope they do.
Yeah.
I wonder if they'll do
like an original song.
Yeah.
That would be crazy.
We should do an original song.
Yeah, why did we learn
not to do an original song?
I'm like, bro, it's stressful,
and I was trying to debut.
Last thing I'm going to do
is give them a custom song
that they like to try and do.
We should all have an original,
we should have a group song
that's an original.
Okay.
I'll do the male part of the song
because my voice can handle that.
I'll do the rap part of the song.
I'll do the backup vocals.
That leaves Azura and Mercy
and Icy.
Perfect.
We're good.
Yeah, they can carry us
through the actual vocals.
Exactly.
I'll just do that.
Yeah.
Who's Adler of everything?
I'm scared of you.
Be lower.
I'm mommy right now,
taking notes, honestly.
Bro, I'm spamming their DMs.
I'm like, how long did that
fucking take?
You're supposed to take it.
Maybe even months, honestly.
Maybe this has been
cooking since day one.
You never know.
I know I want to ask
the girls after.
I want to eat
the strawberries on her head.
I want to eat her.
Shame.
Look at the little saucy wink
she ended on.
She was like...
She knows what she's doing.
She knows it.
Not to make you guys jealous,
but...
Please.
Please, five-man song.
Come on.
Moving on.
I know, I just got scared.
I'm like, what's happening?
I feel out.
Okay.
Oh, my God, I mean...
Really big.
I'm ready.
Oh, it's a five-man.
Let's go.
That's amazing.
What song is this?
Original?
Is this a K-pop song?
Is it K-pop?
Yeah.
What song is this?
I'm wondering...
It makes sense that they picked
a K-pop group.
Yeah, that's true.
Because they all have
girl singers with different parts.
It's a Twice song.
It is a Twice song.
I feel like I would recognize it
if it was a Twice song,
but I guess I'm a fake Twice fan.
Name this particular member's
grandmother's maiden name right now.
Oh, I'm getting tingles.
This is awesome.
Oh, my God.
Can someone tell me what song this is?
It's K-D-A, apparently.
Okay, that makes more sense.
Oh, it's K-D-A?
Yeah.
Why did somebody say it was Twice?
Why are you lying?
Oh, it's I'll Show You by K-D-A and Twice.
Okay.
Song for League of Legends.
Oh, well, that's Azura fucking Happy.
She's probably geeking out right now.
Hold on.
I want to go to her stream.
I'm going to.
She's going to be singing all the words from that one.
We'll listen to Azura singing, too.
Yeah.
She's probably harmonizing with them.
We popped up.
Oh, she's not singing.
Sing for me, Azura.
Sing.
She's just bopping.
She's bopping from her fear right now.
I'm going to say sing.
I do, like, K-D-A songs.
Wow, almost his voice.
I wish I could sing like that, my God.
I wish I could sing in Korean and in Japanese.
That sounds so good.
This is such a great song for all of them.
This must have been a lot of practice, my God.
I like how Azura is just like in the corner.
Is that chair?
I'm leaning hard.
Her voice.
I love Azura.
No, encore!
Give us more!
Mom, I want more!
I want more!
No.
It cannot be.
Encore.
Do the DJ scratch.
Be like, oh, last song.
We don't have time.
And then DJ scratch.
And they're all like, let's go!
After party.
Yeah.
After party!
On Reia's channel?
Yeah.
I'm going to go to Reia's channel right now.
Azura!
Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit.
Wait.
Hold on.
That was really good.
Party, party, party, party, party!
That was insane.
Yeah, dang.
Let's see.
Arm.
Give me one second.
Never more.
I'm going to see if we can either watch it.
If not, I will redirect into her.
I'm going to redirect into her.
How do you redirect without ending stream?
You're not in the stream.
Yeah, you're not in the stream.
You should edit.
Edit video.
Edit video?
Yeah.
Yeah, you edit video or you just go into studio, YouTube studio.
Yeah, but how do you send them?
How do you send your viewers to the stream without ending your own stream?
Oh, I thought I didn't know what you were asking.
Oh, no, I don't know.
You can do that.
You could just post a link and be like, go forth.
In fact, I'm pulling up the link right now.
I'll post a link and then I'm going to chat with everyone for a little bit and then I'm going to redirect.
Okay, I'll do that too.
I'm going to see you guys.
Okay.
Bye.
What is it?
1115.
Oh, she's not pulled up yet.
That's why she's not live.
There you go.
I'm doing remedy for the poor post-concert crisis.
Okay, I will redirect into the waiting room for them briefings.
I'm going to say thank you to Amy.
She'd be keeping me company during this.
Absolutely.
Likewise.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I nailed it.
And business, business, business.
I didn't mean to spam their discord.
I was supposed to do it live once too.
Thank you so much, girls.
I'll talk to you later, all right?
Bye.
Okay.
All right, guys.
That was fun.
That was great.
My God, that was awesome.
It is such a good job.
I'm so impressed with their singing skill.
I didn't know that, like, a lot of them had pipes like that.
And for such a small company to be able to, like,
make something that amazing,
you could see why Stradi was geeking out.
She's feeling very inspired because they did such an amazing job.
And they're so talented.
You, my plus girls are so talented and they're so sweet.
I love spending time with you, my plus girls.
They're literally awesome.
But yeah, head on over to Reyes channel,
the sweet little jote, unfortunately,
right at the end.
I don't know what will consist of the after-party.
It seems like it'll be in 20 minutes.
Looks like everybody's redirecting.
Looks like Rocky from Pixeling's also redirecting.
Okay, yeah.
I think everybody's kind of redirecting into them.
So I'll see you guys later.
Make sure you go check out the watch, the after-party.
So, yeah, I'll probably be in the chat and geeking out with them.
So, bye guys. Love you.
Thank you guys for stopping by and watching this with me
and, like, hearing how goofy that me and the other girls are together.
It's so fun, yeah.
See ya. See you tomorrow for Twilight.
Bye.
I forgot you guys can hear me.
I forgot to bring my mic.
I can almost hear her.
Oh, you can almost hear me.
Oh, I'm a ghost.
It's like you can hear me.
My keyboard's still.
They check out that you might plus girls info in my description.
And go and like their video.
Thank you.
Bye.
You stay.